somebody messaged me on social media
and asked me like hey what's up with
alkaline water you know does it include
increase blood ph if so does it even
matter
and you know one of the things that
comes up a lot there's a lot of
confusion with these
alkaline diets alkaline water
you know one of the questions people ask
is
just simply is it possible to change
blood ph with these types of
interventions
and
i think a lot of people in the
evidence-based community
take a little bit of a shortcut to the
answer no
i don't think that's necessarily true
so we can change blood ph
it's just to a very small extent uh you
know with these types of nutritional
interventions and you know one of the
first places i went with this is like
let's just go straight to the sodium
bicarbonate literature right like it's
a very basic solution that people ingest
and we look at blood ph after ingestion
after exercise and we do see uh in many
in many cases a statistically
significant increase in blood ph
um
but
human blood is
always going to be slightly alkaline
unless you're
in in a you know potentially precarious
situation where it's become you know
blood ph is getting dysregulated um so
you know some type of acidosis is
happening that's clinic clinically
relevant but generally speaking we're
going to try to keep our blood ph
between
7.35 and 7.45 and so yeah when when we
you know consume an extremely basic
beverage
um in high amounts you know so a big
dose of sodium bicarbonate for example
whether it's capsules or beverage or
whatever we might see a statistically
significant increase in ph um i still
don't know if alkaline water is going to
get you there though
because i mean if yeah if you're talking
about
20
depending on your size like 15 to 30
grams of sodium bicarbonate taken before
exercise
dude that's
that's a lot more bicarbonate than you
would be consuming and like a liter of
alkaline water yeah there was the reason
i
expanded out into that literature was
because i did see like one or two
studies where
there is a statistically significant
increase as it was reported because the
samples were enormous
but it just did not matter it was like
the small it was not the same the same
magnitude as sodium bicarbonate but it
was like
yeah we found this effect i assume there
was an enormous correlation from pre to
post test that that kind of helped the
p-value along the magnitude was
just so small it couldn't possibly
matter but
i expanded out because i was like okay
are there other
is there a precedent by which consuming
an alkaline you know
a basic alkaline beverage
like you know a sodium bicarbonate
intervention is there a precedent for
this where we could see an increase and
so the answer is yes
but the answer is also that i just when
it comes to alkaline water like
it's a bit of a shortcut to say like no
it absolutely never could possibly have
any measurable impact on ph but it just
doesn't matter like the the idea that
alkaline water you're going to consume
it and it's going to have a positive
effect on i mean they make all sorts of
claims about stuff ranging from bone
health all the way to like cancer
prevention are you going to consume
alkaline water that's going to change
your blood ph
probably not
even if there was an effect it'd be so
small as to be completely negligible and
will it impact any relevant health
related outcome
none that i can think of so
functionally it doesn't matter the
answer to this question like is there
any reason to be drinking alkaline water
in my opinion no
but i i did want to at least acknowledge
like there there are ways that blood ph
can change to a measurable measurable
degree
but the body has so many
redundant mechanisms to keep it within a
fairly tight operating range
the ph thing just doesn't seem to matter
like you can try to drive it over 7.45
but i mean alkaline water like you said
ain't gonna do it i mean that also still
wouldn't be a good thing no it'd be
terrible it'd be terrible when people
talk about uh like health risk from
blood ph dysregulation they're generally
thinking about
pretty extreme acidosis yeah i mean if
you could put yourself in a comparable
state of alkalosis that would be just as
bad it would not yeah that's yeah it
would not be good it's kind of like one
of those things um i think kind of a
slightly analogous situation is when
people talk about
uh
doing all sorts of weird stuff with
sodium potassium balance
and it's like it's so important to
physiological function that there are a
lot of redundant mechanisms to keep it
within a
tight operating range to the extent
possible
and
in the off chance you are able to
override that stuff it's bad
you know
yeah not good yeah so um when it comes
to alkaline water uh
the the reason i brought up the study
was just because someone
was um they were confused you know they
said like hey man uh everyone's saying
that this can't increase blood ph but
here's a study on pubmed which is
supposed to mean something and it did
and i looked at it i said yes it did it
was statistically significant it was
physiologically meaningless and that's a
good thing you know if if all of a
sudden blood ph was nine you're screwed
yeah you're so screwed it wouldn't
happen but but yeah so alkaline water
not worth your time not worth your money
um but if you ever see um i think it's
good to know that when you're
looking at other research like so for
example sodium bicarb you shouldn't look
at a study that says oh by the way blood
ph increased p is .04 shouldn't look at
that and say well this study got botched
because that's not technically accurate
yeah yeah uh so you you tried to rest
you tried to address that question uh
respectfully sure i just want to dunk a
little bit uh
i would say
god probably a dozen different times
like this isn't just a one or two time
occurrence i'll stumble across on my
like instagram discover page um
like health tips instagram accounts and
i love that [ __ ] like i
if people probably have a completely
inaccurate assumption of what my what my
media consumption habits are i spend
virtually all of my time seeking out
good information
either on pubmed or journal websites or
talking to people who i respect
i
i
consume virtually no
kind of like solid quote unquote fitness
industry content like i know there are
people out there doing good work
i just i just don't read it um
when i am consuming
non-serious content
i'm looking for the trash i want to see
the garbage i love it i think a lot of
people see that stuff and they get
frustrated they're like oh no the state
of the industry this is so bad
i'm very nihilistic i fundamentally
don't think anything is going to get
that much better so i just bathe in it i
i enjoy it i find it so funny um
so anyway in
wading into just the pure
depths of instagram [ __ ]
i've come across
like i said probably at least a dozen
posts from health and fitness
influencers saying look you need to
alkalize your body
that's good for you it's going to
prevent cancer it's going to give you so
much mental clarity and energy and here
are some tips to do it first consume
alco alkaline water duh of course
everyone knows that that's the good
stuff but here's another tip did you
know
uh citrus also alkalizes your body so
put a put a squeeze of lemon juice in
your alkaline water
and
i'm sure
95 of people listening to this
understand why that's funny
ph isn't
it's not a magical thing uh ph stands
for potential hydrogen um so if it's in
so it's basically a measure of how much
hydrogen which like free hydrogen that
is acid uh how much free hydrogen a
thing can accept uh and so
like that that's
a pure kind of like applied chemistry
base based measurement
if you put an acid in a basic substance
it necessarily raises the ph or
necessarily lowers the ph and makes it
more acidic so
i mean if if alkaline water could
elevate blood ph make it more basic
it does i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
claiming that there are magical
properties of lemons that
can also increase blood ph if you put
acidic lemon juice in alkaline water
that shit's not alkaline water anymore
or at least you're making it less
alkaline than it previously was
absolutely incredible i love it so much
if you find
bad fitness content send it to me and
not just
if it's just like a one-off or someone's
just kind of like ah they post some
workout tips and ah whatever and they
just have a stinker i don't care about
that that's not the good stuff you want
the shock value i want i want the worst
of the worst and here's the gold mine if
you find a
a single account that like
40 to 70 of what they post is pure
garbage
send it to me i love it i want to fill
my instagram feed with meme pages dog
pages and the worst fitness content
imaginable so uh
anyway
that's all i'm gonna say if if you come
across someone who's pushing alkaline
water in combination with citrus fruit
cut up cut them out of your life and put
them into mine you should expand you you
mentioned dog pages
really any mammal will do i've got a lot
of raccoon pages i've got some bear
pages i'm a sucker for animal friend
accounts
what does that mean like two animals of
a different species that are buddies
yeah yeah yeah like cross species
friendships yeah i like that a lot but
yeah yesterday i was pretty deep looking
at a bunch of panda content the red
panda
very cute very good stuff um but i guess
the moral of the story is
there's no reason to drink alkaline
water but um technically
you know certain interventions could
have a statistically significant
significant effect on blood
ph but it's still going to stay within
that tight range that that's typical
because
i mean
we're good at managing that and we're
pretty lucky that we're good at managing
that
there was one other thing i was going to
say about this
and i have completely lost it um
if it comes back to me
i will let you know do i see you
i see in the outline you have some stuff
about breathing and how that regulates
ph no i was going to get into the
mechanisms of how we regulate ph but
we're just good at it um
and good for us
if you want to alkyl if you want to
alkalize your body uh one thing you
could do is just hyperventilate for a
while
yeah like if you there was a um did you
cover that mass i did yeah yeah um but
yeah if you wanted
to just see like hey if i were to
alkalize my body how would that make me
feel you can get kind you can get
relatively close to the limits of
human blood alkalinity just via
respiratory alkalosis uh which you can
get to just by hyperventilating you're
blowing off co2 uh and like the co2
carbonic acid relationship like that
that's one of the ways that your body
regulates ph via your lungs and kidneys
like those are the two main things
so if you're just blowing off a ton of
co2 by hyperventilating you put yourself
in in a state of respiratory alkalosis
so you know if if you want to see
how you feel uh as your as your blood ph
approaches uh
7.45
you can do it um
have fun
yes
i remember the thing i was going to say
thank you for uh filling that time there
with a lovely anecdote with good advice
with good advice
um one thing to keep in mind if you are
looking through this literature is that
urine ph is way more responsive to
dietary fluctuations than blood ph so
be sure not to confuse those sometimes
we kind of convince ourselves oh
blood values urine values whatever it's
all the same but one of the redundant
mechanisms you know we have all these
overlapping mechanisms for ph control
one of the mechanisms is that your
kidneys can kind of decide hey how much
should we be pumping into the urine here
to just kind of balance things out yeah
that is why blood ph can be so tightly
controlled yeah like you're uh
what is it your entire blood volume
filters through your kidneys every five
minutes or something like that i've
never heard that but i believe it and
it's also crazy at the same time i
believe that's the case so yeah if you
uh manage to create a relatively large
perturbation in blood ph uh
via some
non-pathological means
uh
you're you're going to like all of that
blood that you just alkalized is going
to pass through your kidneys within the
next five minutes and if the level of
alkalinity got
high enough to even begin threatening
your body's homeostasis
you're just gonna put a bunch of
bicarbonate in your urine and now now
your blood ph is back to normal so
that that is another thing like even if
you can perturb blood ph those
perturbations are going to be very
short-lived oh yeah very transient very
short-lived and and that is why urine ph
can vary quite a bit more like if if
something kind of acidic is going on and
you have
more acidity in your blood uh those
excess hydrogen ions are going to very
quickly be filtered into urine and
you're going to piss them out if your
body does get considerably more alkaline
um
and you'll you'll also uh
increase respiration to to alkalize your
blood as well i don't want to make it
sound like it's all urine
but yeah if your body gets more alkaline
you'll just put more bicarbonate in your
urine and and get rid of it so yeah any
perturbations
not only are they generally quite small
but they're also quite short-lived as
well